we now come to five most amazing
discovered checks what I like to call
the ambush move or Jennifer Hardy has
called the peek-a-boo peek-a-boo and
remember to like and subscribe to this
channel and video and we can have a look
at some amazing chess examples now on to
example number one this very famous
example was actually played in 1910 and
is probably the most famous example of
that discovered check being used in a
tactical sequence but Richard reti had
the white pieces and his opponent was
tired of covert to elite players in that
history markers point so it's white to
play and how did white now unleash a
devastating checkmating attack through a
combination of very strong and bizarre
looking first move remember you can't
pause these videos if you need to well
Queen to d8 check and this is a shocking
first move because you give the Queen up
for nothing but now the theme of this
YouTube video dis ambush that we have so
wherever we move the bishop it's going
to be check and after Bishop to g5 we
produce a double check and this is the
discovered check tactic the rook is
released
wherever the King goes is going to be
checkmate the game apparently finished
King c7 Bishop d8 beautiful checkmate
and had the King gone to e8 the rook now
lands on that square also delivering
checkmate so we're gonna move on to
another example now we're gonna stick
with some famous and well-known examples
of this for now and we have 4a with the
white pieces against Alaska it must have
been all the rage this discovered
checking around this period of history
and I suppose we could say this next
example is the most famous example of a
sort of technique of the discovered
check called the
windmill it's white to play and win here
and I also like calling this the Hoover
hmm you just hover up or your opponent's
pieces what is the winning move for
white here what it is
Bishop to f6 creating a threat against
g7 and also the Queen's are now opposing
each other and on pre-black really has
to take the White Queen our vice is
completely lost and now we see this
windmill discovered Czech idea rook
takes G so the black King only has one
square the bishop has this potential
discovered check and you can see the
sort of reason it's called a windmill
here don't let me do to me movements
rook to f7 check and the King only has
one square the rook goes back to g7
check only has one square and now the
rook continues its windmill technique
taking everything it can do in its path
pretty much and only now going to g5
again another discovered check but this
time white grabs the Queen and goes into
your position with domination of
material and an easily winning position
at this level so a very famous windmill
there and we've got one more good
historic example to come after this this
is again a very famous one the next two
examples after us a bit more modern but
I had to include it because I think the
final little move has a bit of sense of
humor now I'm going to whiz through the
little tactical sequence which you may
have seen white to play and win do pause
if you need to but it starts off with a
stunning Queen sacrifice this has to be
taken and now we have the first
discovered Czech ambush or peekaboo
Knight takes f6 the bishop also and
dominates the King here the King can't
go back as a knight g6 checkmate so it
has to come forwards and now white keeps
on chasing the black King down the board
look at that black King embarrassing
wandering to death and it now touched
down on g1 and there are a couple of
ways to win here but I really like the
next move King D to checkmate
how many times in chess can you move a
king and give checkmate
you can never move a King into check so
you have to move it away with a
discovered checkmate and that is an
astonishing example that I might have
even prefered castling queenside would
check mates but I hope it's in the eye
of the beholder well this is a very
famous example because it occurred in
1995 this game and it helped Garry
Kasparov who was playing black become
world champion this is in his World
Championship match against command
fisherman Anand and it is white to play
and announce now went for the fork you
might see that in a previous video
Knight to b6 but Gary had set up a very
nasty discovered check idea he first
takes on b4 and now Annan plays King a
free actually putting black into another
fork both works are attacked and this is
the position where black needs to find a
good move can you see it only one move
otherwise Garry is lost rook takes a to
the move that Anand must missed and
appoint this move both black rooks are
on pre but you can't take both of them
at once
if King takes b4 black simply takes on
d2 with a winning position wise pawns
are dropping and maybe the slightly
trickier line after rook takes c2 is
white taking on c2 but now we use a
discovered check we first check on be
free white can only move to a2 and like
the previous example lining up into the
bishops like shall we say range there so
black can do a discovered check rookie
free being a good one when the rook next
move have a to porn advantage so nice
little tactical
sequence there and in the next case it's
an ins chance to shine well this is
probably one of my favorite ones of the
whole five examples and this occurred
we've added with the white pieces in
1997 against a very strong French player
Joel lutea and announce it now played h6
a rather unassuming move
but after lutea took on h6 and I've had
a devastatingly beautiful idea here and
this really requires some talent and
imagination
what is the winning move that Anand now
played again pause if you need to
Bishop to g6 and this is an example of a
discovered attack against the opposing
king but gaining tempo to also start an
attack against well the king so the king
and queen of both attacked him and black
is now in a lot of trouble losing in
actual fact if black decides to take the
Queen on d1 we can now play rook takes
c6 check and we can see yh6 was so
important
this is pinned the King really has to
move and now Bishop comes that Square
that Harry the H Paul created and Bishop
takes f7 is a beautiful checkmate so a
lovely move Bishop g6 and the game
actually defend it at ended now after
Bishop takes g6 with Knight to e7 but
white simplified things with Queen takes
Queen and now rook to d3 and the point
of these simplifications is that after
Bishop d3 the black Bishop is trapped
King is going to get that piece and I'll
add some piece up lovely final example I
love that Bishop g6 move please do like
and subscribe to this video let me know
your favorite discovered check from
those five I'd also be interested to
hear if you've managed to pull off a
nice discovered check in your life
they're quite rare but they're also very
satisfying when they occur